when it comes to mental health the
United States has a long way to go from
caring for those with mental illness to
changing public perception and often we
get it so wrong
here are four myths about mental health
in the u.s. myth number one mental
illness is rare actually one in four
adults experiences mental illness every
year that includes everything from
depression to eating disorders OCD and
schizophrenia even celebs like Jon Hamm
Lena Dunham and Lady gaga have spoken
out about the importance of addressing
mental health issues of their own
bipolar depression really got my life
off track but today I'm proud to say I'm
living proof that someone can live love
and be well with bipolar disorder when
they get the education support and
treatment they need myth number two if
the mentally ill just wanted help they
could get it well getting treatment in
the u.s. is not so easy 90 million
Americans live in places without easy
access to mental health assistance
between 2009 and 2012 states cut 5
billion dollars for mental health
services in 1950 there was one
psychiatric bed for every 300 Americans
and in 2010 that number was one in 7100
how did it get so bad in the 1980s
President Ronald Reagan nationalized a
trend that started in his home state of
California moving people out of hospital
psychiatric wards federal mental health
spending went down by 30 percent many
were left without proper care often
becoming homeless or imprisoned today up
to 30 percent of homeless people have a
serious mental illness that's five times
the rate in the general population and
there are 10 times as many mentally ill
people behind bars as in state hospitals
myth number three mentally ill people
are violent when we do talk about mental
health in the u.s. it's often on the
heels of tragedies like murder the
copilot who crashed flight 9525 into the
Alps killing 149 people and himself had
a mental illness CBS News has learned
that James Holmes had seen at least
three mental health professionals Lanza
had significant mental health issue
but only three to five percent of
violent acts in the United States are
committed by people with serious mental
illness in fact people with mental
illness are 10 times more likely to be
victims of violent crimes than the rest
of society and of the 38,000 people who
commit suicide each year it's estimated
that 90% have had a mental illness and
people with serious mental illness die
up to 23 years sooner than other
Americans myth number four fixing the
system is just too expensive
well taxpayers actually end up paying
more for the consequences of mental
illness than they would for preventive
treatment for every two to three
thousand dollars spent each year on
treating the mentally ill $50,000 is
saved on incarceration costs so after
all this maybe it's the system that's
truly insane